I'm wearing this hazmat suit are you let
me see yeah what I do is when I get here
I change into this doesn't fit me that
great but it's not bad
I thought you just had on a white oh no
no this is a hazmat suit you can see I
have an anti bedbug emblem patch I'm not
happy about it I don't want to look like
this on camera ah you know so they found
a bedbugs in my car they must have been
in here and they dragged him in so what
did they do with the car
well it was supposed to be an hour
yesterday where they put the the car
under extreme heat and then the bugs
died in the heat
Ronnie comes in this morning and he says
well they didn't take the car for 24
hours I said well what are they doing he
goes oh they're putting they're pumping
poison gas into the car oh great
so I don't even want to use my car
anymore pumping I said Ronnie why would
you be steamed the car I said Ronnie why
did you allow them to pump poison gas
into the car he goes well the guy said
it's safe get in the car that was in
pump full of poison gas but the [ __ ] is
wrong with them
ronbo what is this poison gas I mean I'm
going nuts from this look at you yeah
[ __ ] you told me to get the car
straightened out yeah get it straight up
but use your hand or goes in he walks
around smell some [ __ ] no you're
getting yelled at cuz you why would you
allege that the process is the best way
to do it the best way but I gotta sit in
there I don't want to be that's why
chemicals I'm completely [ __ ]
paranoid what I was told to do and I
mean you know what always check with me
cuz I'm really good about I told you I
was going in and hell I know but I
didn't you should call me poison gas
when you hear poison guess I'm calling
Howard I don't want any poison gas hey
remember the bedbugs do the poison gas
use Howard for your brain you're gonna
be a lot better off I'll think let me do
the thinking
you know you need my help your left if
you left it up to me the [ __ ] car
would have went nowhere I would have
just left it the way it was
I think Hitler used poison yeah you know
what I'm saying yeah here's a few rules
for from now on if you hear the words
poison gas in any scenario call Howard
alright whenever you hear poison gas
those two words should trigger something
you know if I didn't want to listen to
anybody I wanted to do my own thing I
would let them buy the car now let them
just give them the car
tell them they can keep it I don't want
it I'll [ __ ] get a pet you get a
capetti cab and drive yeah thank you
peddle you [ __ ] pedal me to work
blame me for this whole thing boys and
gas say who do you work
they said the game you know I'm the
[ __ ] sitting here you know I'm
[ __ ] crazy they said it wasn't the
same thing they told you here that it's
not gonna harm you
yeah that's exactly what they told me
they didn't use poison gas here notice
that I don't know how this became my
fault who said it's your was he yelling
at me I said I yelling I'm John do we
discuss with you here poison gas when
someone says to you poison gas get
alarmed we discuss this with you
yesterday when I was no you didn't yes
we did I never heard poison gas you
never take us okay we're gonna gas the
car oh you didn't you didn't run all
right you told me that they're doing a
24-hour process right to make sure they
get rid of the bugs right well that's
what the guy told me take the water
there was all the water bottles in the
car right so if the guy tells you take
all the water bottles out of the car cuz
they know they'll be no good anymore
they'll be destroyed what does that mean
here's what is it is what means if the
whatever you're doing is gonna destroy a
water bottle a piece of plastic what do
you think it's gonna do to a human being
all right why not blow up the car to
kill the bedbugs that's we should that
month we're gonna take a stick of
dynamite and blow this [ __ ] up and I'm
gonna guarantee about overkill poison
gas I'm not getting in the car that had
poison gas I mean what a [ __ ] is rising
that hey now Ronnie how are you getting
a new car kid I have this company buy a
new car I gotta go
[ __ ] guys are pissing me off and
who's yelling at you I just wish you
would call me he knows I think for him
this is his first thought and look at it
oh my god
you